the earth is a dying rock and time is
running out
you only have 10 years to plan your
escape
how could we evacuate as many people as
possible
what resources would we need to take to
survive
and
where would we go
this is what if and here's what would
happen if earth had 10 years left
if we found out that earth only had 10
years left before it was destroyed we'd
need to figure out a plan for humanity
to survive
and with a global population of 7.8
billion people
our survival plan would have to be as
colossal as possible
today's space shuttle technology can
only transport five to seven people into
space at a time
this means we would need over one
billion shuttles to carry everyone off
the planet
that's not very feasible
we'd need bigger spacecraft and fast
to design and build the spacecraft at
breakneck speed we would all need to
work together
yeah
we'd need to set aside all our wars and
conflicts to help make the plan succeed
we'd need to bring the best and
brightest people to our new home
including scientists doctors engineers
and maintenance crews
everyone would need to keep the ships
and future settlements up and running
i'm imagining the selection process to
go would be very strict so if you wanted
to be one of those survivors
you'd have to find a way to stand out
and nothing will make you stand out
better than a brilliantly written cover
letter now
writing isn't always easy
especially when your fate depends on it
but with grammarly premium you might
just write the perfect piece
my team and i we use grammarly all the
time to make sure our stories sound
engaging and clear and that they have
zero grammar mistakes i'm a bit of a
grammarista i even use grammarly when i
write my emails and it doesn't matter
whether i'm on my phone or on my
computer with the grammarly browser
plugin i can make sure my grammar
punctuation and style are sharp across
all my correspondence it gradually does
more than just check spelling so say
what you really mean with grammarly
premium and get twenty percent off
grammarly premium by signing up at
grammarly.com
what if that's twenty percent off at g r
a m a r l y dot com slash what if
and now that you have more chances to be
picked as a survivor
you might want to know what comes next
there would have to be intense
screenings to make sure that only
healthy people relocate off earth
a single outbreak of disease
could spell the end of humanity
now it would be impossible to bring
everyone
we have to leave a lot of people on the
dying rock
but how many could we save
well by some estimates we'd only need to
save 98 people
yeah that would be enough for humanity
to survive and maintain a healthy
population
other scientists argue we'd need at
least 14 000 people
okay so let's round this up and say
we'll aim for evacuating 15 000 people
now
how do we choose them i choose
you
well it could come down to population
sizes here on earth
for example india could send 2 700
people to account for their
percent of the global population
while the united states could send 600
to match its 4.25 percent of the
population
or would we choose people based solely
on their skills and qualifications
this would perpetuate many of today's
inequalities
who we choose would have huge impacts on
humanity's cultures and attitudes in the
future
to maintain all the cultures on earth we
would need to find ways to preserve them
okay now let's get to the technical side
of things
to carry 15 000 people to refuge in
space
we would need an enormous ship
or many smaller ones
now while constructing one ship might be
most efficient
there would be significant risk if that
ship became damaged or malfunctioned
two of the biggest challenges would be
figuring out how to build such a complex
spacecraft and
where it will not be easy for you to
hear you know building it in space could
give us more freedom
we could optimize the ship for space
conditions rather than engineering it to
survive the brutal trip from earth
and it could help if we transfer the raw
materials to space before beginning
construction but that would take a while
currently spacex rockets can carry a
maximum payload of 63 800 kilograms and
we'd need a lot more than that
we would need to build our space vessel
to become self-sustaining
solar power would be the primary energy
source
after all it's free and the sun will
keep burning for billions of years
but everything would need to be in
perfect balance to produce oxygen and
water grow food
process waste and regulate the
temperature and pressure
but first we would need to stock the
ship with enough food to keep everyone
alive before we can start growing food
in space
to survive the first two years you alone
would need up to 400 kilograms of food
and that food would have to contain all
the carbs fats proteins and fiber you'd
need to stay healthy
you'd also need 1726
liters of water per person okay now
multiply those numbers by 15 000 to
supply everyone on board with enough
food and water
uh
that would be a lot of water so our ship
would use cutting edge methods of
recycling to make a renewable water
system
but where would we go
well first we'd establish a pit stop for
deeper space exploration
luckily by the time the evacuation began
we'd already have one orbiting the moon
designed to resupply astronauts with
food and oxygen
then we might head to mars where we
could orbit it for a while
but we'd need to figure out how to get
everyone down onto the red planet
[Music]
could we accomplish all that in a mere
10 years
well we already have the drive
technology and financing to make
civilian space travel possible in the
near future
but it would take much longer than 10
years to complete such a global
evacuation mission
so maybe we should start getting ready
now
you know mars looks like a good place to
terraform
but
that's a story
for another
what if
you